please tell me that y'all did not hear
me singing there's a lot of people sing
I know was about the greatest though
know was he's like I was just happy with
all the children they're like if you're
just getting to see it again to them
well it's also like the first time
seeing it with young kids it's like oh
wow this is like even the original Lion
King is is there's a you know people
think of the funny stuff but there's a
big emotional roller coaster in it and
and with all the young kids and they
were hanging in there yeah it's too much
it's like is this - its photo real you
know so it's like but they boy and and
you've always been really encouraging
about that because you're going through
it now yeah you're you know you got your
circle of life it's such a but it's such
a great you forget like this morning my
son was running around the house being a
lion yeah I mean like wouldn't come to
breakfast unless I was like I was like
hey breakfast was ready he's like so I'm
like lion breakfast like I'm its it you
forget how important this movie is it
sets up I don't know it gives you a
narrative it's such a simple narrative
for like the rest of your life you
understand like oh we're part of this
thing it was going it's great it's
interesting because you told me last
night that he was you weren't gonna tell
him that you were in the film yeah you
said you want to go see it oh yeah
Beyonce he said oh yeah yeah I'm saying
it like kind of like that's the one with
Beyonce did you ever tell him before or
did he see last night and recognize my
voice dad is symbol that was last night
he gave me the when I came on screen he
was like take a couple looking you know
and my wife was like like oh he's
getting a he's getting it like it was it
was really special
yeah I don't because I don't know how
that's ever gonna happen ever again in
the history of like humans where I'm
like I know the movie he knows the movie
yes you know it's so ironic too because
I know I was introduced to Donald
originally through my son who had his
picture up on his wall and then also my
daughter's my wife
you know such Beyonce fans so I was
introduced to all of this through that I
know both of you all I mean you both
walked out of there with your kids as
King last night especially hearing there
was that moment when it was the
transformation from Young soon but yeah
people are yelling and then trying to be
quiet so they could hear like a little
it's that edge and I know that from
working on comedies because when a
comedies works that's exactly it people
laugh and then choke the laugh off yeah
because they won't want to miss anything
that whole component Simba I mean Timon
and Pumbaa with hahaha what like all I
was dying I was like people are really
laughing so hard that they're trying to
listen to so now I know I have to go see
it again I'm gonna go in like that first
show at 9:00 a.m. that when I'm
hopefully by myself and I could just
watch it did you get to introduce your
son to Beyonce since he knew did she get
to meet her he was so tired he was so he
was so done but he met I mean like well
she was behind us so like the of IV Blue
was like kind of narrowing the movie
Simon like
[Music]
I mean like John is very aware of like
the uncanny valley and like how movies
work and how they should feel like he's
a very organic guy like I'm gonna I'm
gonna and and I think right now speaking
to the circle circle of life it's really
important to know like we're moving so
fast and we're losing recipes a little
bit like we're kind of losing like all
the flavor of like why people even did
certain things in certain places for
certain reasons and with filmmaking the
magic of it is the collaboration and how
you make it in the fact that he was able
to bring all the best parts of
filmmaking into a game engine and make
it feel so I mean when he even had me
put those glass I was like this is this
is how movies should be made by now I
try and do that with any any work I do
like with well you cross over so many
different things you got the kind of
brain where you could see something or
something with music inspires something
and cinema for you or something and I
know I like that you came from we're
talking even before you came in here the
fact that you worked in a writers room
like Ana comedy writers room which is
there's nothing precious about that at
all it's about just let's get together
let's make it funny and let's move on
and the show must go on and then you got
Atlanta where you're taking out you're a
filmmaker and also coming from all that
and I knew part of the Hope was showing
you that stuff because it wasn't just
about okay let's perform but then we
would spend a long time in the like a
lab on them in the volume with somebody
like you once you see what tools are out
there what's available I know it's gonna
inspire yes thank you it's so important
like people I don't think people will
know for a little bit like couple years
and they'll look back and be like oh
like this movie was it transformed and
I'm so glad it's him and I'm so glad
it's the Lion King but there's
out there that people don't know is fake
too because that's also good like you
could use it for to tell a good story to
bring people together but there's also
you can't always trust what you're
seeing sometimes because it's you know
they're they could make will right at
that edge where it becomes
indistinguishable so it's good to see
what it could be used for but I think
it's also different people understand
what the technical the technology is now
and an understanding that you got to
make sure you know what you're watching
and know know that it's not you know
you're not being misled
[Music]